[Applause]
the Russians only understand violence so
I showed them
understand why we do hey because they
killed our soldiers now look at them
[Applause]
the US and allies bombed
Iraqi soldiers as they tried to flee
Kuwait and return to Iraq the highway of
death the russians bombed it during the
invasion killing the peoples trying to
escape we want to present the different
perspectives we don't want to say that
one of them is correct claude starts out
trying to blur the lines between good
and bad but it ends up quickly
establishing the good guys as very
clearly good that's right it's cool to
shoot at russia again
then you kill Russians yes they will be
white LED burka I make no distinction
between alcohol and the Russian army
they're both terrorists manyanya try
since America to lose me bar comma
you